thank you guys for coming you're gonna
need to walk this off or run it off
because I'm the flower girl supporters
we heard from the guys what did you just
do
I joined got peanuts room bar
[Music]
everybody we got new flash to break down
Katee Sackhoff is finally here as the
blacksmith character from the comics if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get everything
they'll be giveaway stuff at the end of
the video but the big deal here is that
Amunet black the person that they've
been hyping up since the end of episode
1 is finally making herself known and
she is sort of the de facto leader of
what remains of the Rogues in the city
like there's a whole idea that all these
rogues are running around captain cold
sort of used to be the top dog
technically he's dead right now because
of all the stuff that's happening with
legends of tomorrow but power abhors a
vacuum so naturally some other rogue
would step up and that's pretty much the
way it happened in the comics it's right
out of early Jeff Jones wally west era
flash he did this big thinker arc
Amunet black was a big part of that even
though they weren't necessarily working
together she ran a black market
operation called the network and just
had a ton of rogues working for her so
presumably that's what Caitlyn was doing
during the break between seasons if we
don't get Blache backs to that we'll
probably just get lines of dialogue from
Amunet just saying remember when you did
this for me or you did that it in the
promo pic she does go full-blown killer
frost so presumably at some point during
all this crazy bachelor bachelorette
party stuff she finally loses her [ __ ]
in what looks like the most SummerSlam
edition of a bachelorette party ever
Stephen Amell is probably so sad that he
didn't get to guest star in the
SummerSlam crossover episode this year
there's an alternate edition of this
promo where the girls are just
practicing their wrestling moves
smashing tables and chairs over each
other but obviously you have all that
stuff going on it is an arrow crossover
because they have Felicity I don't know
if they're gonna have any Oliver stuff
in the episode because there's actually
kind of hard to do crossover episodes so
if we don't see a lot of him in the
episode it's just because his schedule
was so crazy and when you're the main
actor on one of the TV shows like if
you're Barry or you're Oliver you're
almost in every single scene of an
episode in right now they're filming
episode 9 for both of the TV shows I
think they're almost done filming their
midseason finale crossover episodes but
the producers said the part of the
conceit is is that some
happens to berry while they're at this
bachelor party like he says I went to
the bar to get peanuts so either he's
using Kaitlyn's special alcohol or some
special formula to allow him to get
drunk like hey we want you to have a fun
time so we're gonna make something
special for you so that the alcohol
doesn't burn through your system
basically if I had her proof I figured
if anybody could use a drink tonight
it was you so here's to bet
Oh that'd you quick pretty buzz um yeah
yeah I'm buzzed for sure whoa oh good
stuff you have that funny moment with
Barry just blurting out that he's the
flash this is another one of those
episodes you could tell in Joe West
reaction shots just as things get
progressively worse and worse for them
the funny thing here is that you see
Cecile pick up one of the champagne
glasses I don't think she actually takes
a drink in the episode because she's
pregnant and drinking while you're
pregnant is kind of like playing with a
loaded gun like so many bad things could
happen during your pregnancy but I don't
think that that's gonna have anything to
do with what actually ends up happening
with the baby down the road regardless
of what happens to the Cecile character
if something bad does happen to her baby
it'll be some more flash comic book II
related thing like the show isn't so
pessimistic that it would hurt a
premature baby by having Cecile be a bad
mom by getting super drunk when she's
pregnant could you even imagine the
waves of hate the CW would get from a
large portions of the fandom but I can
already feel all the crazy crackpot
reddit theories rising up drinking while
she's pregnant that's how you get your
Daniel West reverse-flash the cool thing
about this character here that iris is
cold clocking with the tray obviously we
saw him back during episode one he's
working for Amunet black in the context
of the TV show his name is nour vog but
that character in the comics was from
like the Golden Age the original version
of The Thinker worked for him he was a
mob boss so even though it seems like
they're doing something different with
him on the TV show he does have a link
to the thinker in the comics but I don't
know if they're gonna do that on the TV
show as well too but it seems like so
far in the way that the thinker is
manipulating the 12 metahumans on the TV
show even if he's not directly engaged
with people he's still pulling the
strings from behind trying to get them
to do what he wants them to do but I
know a lot of you are wondering what am
units powers are she has Meccano Kinesis
so she can control metal like make
herself suits of armor like she forms
the metal around her fist as she smashes
the glass in the trailer
comic book version of her when she's got
this blue looking apparatus all over her
that's just a metal suit that she
constructs around herself so we'll see
if they take it that far in the episode
I know it's a little bit harder to do
that practically and make it look cool
but this is the episode right before the
big Council of Welles episode so we can
talk about that when we get more footage
for that but if you didn't watch legends
of tomorrow they basically did their et
episode it was kind of a Halloween
episode too because the episode aired on
Halloween probably the best one from the
season so I recommend you check it out
if you haven't been watching legends of
tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
Hey
but what will happen next is is I have a
new Titans video we might actually get
Roy Harper the character on Titans but
that doesn't necessarily mean that
Colton Haynes would cross over to Titans
so I'll do a video explaining who the
new characters are they're just doing
more Teen Titans characters from the
comics Roy Harper is a Titans character
there been so many different versions of
him on TV so far but there's a new round
of that flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber or
leave a comment on this video
Thor Ragnarok is this weekend - so I'll
be posting Easter Egg videos and more
spoilery reviews and stuff across the
weekend click here for my episode 4
video and you can click here to learn
all about what's going on with Shazam
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight